you
hi everyone it's Jerry let's have a look
at a game from 1994 this was played at
the 8th Herve Memorial on the white end
Vasily Ivana
paired against Garry Kasparov so two
kings of the initiative on board each
player loves being the one throwing the
punches dictating play and we get to see
this as early as move 10 so let's see
how it develops the opening is an open
Sicilian and the variation knight or
white immediately works with a pawn duo
in this one and when I see this duo I
think about the stability of the King
Knight at any moment it can be brought
into question so Kasparov takes a step
to secure the King Knight from here
Queen f3 and black prepares a king side
fee and keto after Bishop III after
these last two moves by white it appears
White's hinting that he wants to Castle
queenside Bishop g7 sure enough and Age
3 so some prep work is necessary by
white before he can Castle queenside as
otherwise Bishop g4 will sting that'd be
a skewer moreover h3 is simply
facilitating a g4 advance a move that is
desirable in opposite sides castling
positions and it appears that's the
direction we're going in opposite sides
castles in this position black and
Castle kingside
but instead challenges White's pawn duo
white now sees this as an opportunity to
seize the initiative
pop quiz to you what did I von Schuch
play next feel free to pause the video
okay here we go first a capture on e5
this has now opened up the Queen's eyes
to f6 and placed a constraint on the
Dragon Bishop who now has a defensive
role well
Bishop h6 now looking to deflect the
dragon Bishop this is what happens
Bishop takes Bishop in the game
this Knight will go down next what if
black try something different in this
position I want to draw some attention
to this because I could see many players
not want to give up the knight I would
be one of them because the move 95 all
by itself is a good improvement for the
night if it can also get there not be
captured and be throwing a punch all the
better
now for example if black castles in this
position what would be the winning
continuation for white feel free to
pause the video ok if black castles like
this and says I want to keep my knight
here to defend against 95 that doesn't
work because of this sequence and in the
end ninety five hits anyway with a four
there goes the Queen not only is white
up a piece here but is once more
throwing a punch
you cannot castle your way out of the
Bishop h6 move that's the short story in
the game Kasparov plays the best reply
Bishop takes h6 allowing Queen takes
Knight choices are very limited for
black the rook is under fire
castles now
sure enough 95 be careful not only is
the Queen hit but white is a moment away
from a game ender 97 King is without a
square black hits back that's a check
white hits right back with B for this is
not a moment to just say uh let's just
go here
no you hit back you block the check you
throw a punch right back so now the
Queen is under fire making one threat
right around the corner what does black
do there's only one saving move here
what is it feel free to pause the video
okay the best defensive move here is
Bishop g7 Kasparov does not make this
move why is this best well after pawn
takes Queen Bishop takes Queen Knight
takes bishop at the moment white is up a
piece but after King g7 both Knights are
under fire
black will get one of them back Kasparov
doesn't see this instead drops the Queen
back to d8 and soon enough how often do
you see this Kasparov is without a queen
after just 16 moves there's some work to
be done it's true that white has a queen
Black has well after pawn takes knight
in the game black has a dark square
bishop and a knight as compensation for
this Queen loss Black is close to having
nice coordination so it's instructive to
see how white tries to break down or
interfere with Blacks coordination from
here on out first of all some
development some pressure on f7 knight
c6 the queen is under fire Queen c5 and
Bishop e3 so what do you do here as
white
I'm not going to throw a pop quiz your
way but I want to draw some attention to
the strength of this bishop it's not a
three-point piece anymore this is a
really strong piece more like a rook in
value can't castle in either direction
and it's gluing things together
harmony coordination is what black must
have when fighting against the Queen
here working with this imbalanced state
what is white Duke rook to f1 so this
isn't necessarily well there's some
coordination on f7 but what's the deeper
point we see with this next move rook F
3 white recognizes the strength of this
Bishop and is ready to knock it out
Bishop e6 rook takes Bishop sure enough
eliminating this wonderful piece after
pawn takes we have Bishop takes Bishop
Queen takes pawn a new imbalance in this
position what are we working with here
White has a pawn and a queen versus a
rook and a knight now you have to be
delicate here as white there are
opportunities for black to construct
some fortress
first of all a 5 is met with b5 if you
capture you're bringing the RIP to life
and you know you don't want to give that
rook that kind of activity b5 the deeper
point behind this white is kind of
saying you know what i want to keep my
b-pawn around and now i'm gonna go
hunting for your beep on so that this
beep on can be passed this is a
liability for black and this will this
will be the one weak point in blacks
position the King will do a good job
securing this structure this is this is
the weak point in this position so if
you're just doing a scan of this
position or from trying to assess this
position or identify targets this is the
one guy that sticks out to me the pawn
on b7
go after that if you put pressure on it
that means one of the black pieces will
be in a different will have to
a defensive role from here okay to see a
queen side castles rook c5 this Knight
has a nice square rook to d5 white wants
an exchange once in exchange and if he
gets that that means that the knight
doesn't have its favorite square I don't
know where else the knight would stand
well if it's not on e6 where would it go
so you can't capture here this night is
so clumsy I have to go to d8
so no capture here instead be 6 from
here Queen g3 so looking to get in here
possibly trying to get out the beep on
is the plan
rook c7 Queen d6 and the pawns are
doubled so you have to be a little bit
careful here for sure there's some
pressure against c2 rook d2 is there to
defend Queen takes b2 is allowing
unnecessary counter play rook takes c2
and it's unclear it's saying white is a
tiny bit better this is just something
you should not allow at all just address
your opponent's threat rook to d2 in the
game and now black has to go completely
passive rook b7 very sad move to make
you know they're on a half-open file and
to now go to a closed file just to
babysit not fun so how to break this
position down further
it appears black has
fine coordination we play on the
kingside we try and rattle this
construction somehow so how do we do
this 95 cleanup 6 this is a poison pun
Knight takes pawn in this position is
met with rook d8 and after King g7 check
you're gonna be winning the night if you
block with the knight you take advantage
of the pin so taking here no good in the
game it's h6 b 5 rook to e8 and h4 king
h7 how would you advance from this
position one of these two moves is
played next which one would you play
next and why feel free to pause the
video okay the move played in the game
h5 without question this is the better
of the two I want to draw some attention
to this little detail because these
little details add up it's a game of
inches and soon instead of working with
inches you're staring at feet h5 is far
better because well first of all let's
consider this one if g v g5 is met with
h5 keeping things closed and there's
only one base point black needs to be
concerned with f7 or at least near the
king there would only be f7 black needs
to be concerned with defending h5 does
what on the other hand after the reap i
g5 noticed that there is now an avenue
along this diagonal towards the king
notice that the Queen however minimal it
is her mobility has now increased
without the pawn on g6 it sees one step
further to the right h6 is now under
fire which means the King is now without
a move a king move and h6 will go down
don't forget also that the rook is also
a piece that can have an influence on
the h6 squared we'll see how
that plays a role some tactical
sequences on the h6 point something you
don't get if you play the move g5 in
this position h5 in the game is met with
g5 from here rook d6 rook to e6 and
Queen to d8 it's very important black is
not long enough from organizing a
fortress as an example not saying this
is a fortress right here but black is
close to having some kind of fortress
if this capture occurs Knight takes X
and this is the only weak point if black
can somehow get these moves in I believe
we would be staring at a fortress so
just as an example let's just say
there's some dummy moves here right
white doesn't do anything for a couple
moves
if black could get this kind of move in
here something like this I know making
several moves but I just want to
highlight a configuration that black can
shoot for notice there's how everything
is now glued together starting with that
rook defending to important base points
everything is strung together the
evaluation is reading close to zero but
you cannot trust that I believe that
this would be a fortress position it's
close by white needs to recognize this
and does does not capture on e6 allows
the rook to just sit on the d6 Square
Queen to d8 in the game from here King
g7 if there's a capture the pawn is
recapturing in thank you very much I
have a passed pawn to work with King g7
in the game and H excuse me a3 so I
think this is white basically saying to
black you are running out of moves the
last move by black to play to g7 is well
one of the ideas is to safeguard against
Queen f8 there there are ideas of Queen
f8 and rook to d8 and then looking for
me on the back rank
so after King g7 we have a three a four
King B 2 and what does black do in the
game we have rook to e7 trying something
other than this this move so for example
let's just say black goes here right
everything seems to be wonderful
everything is defended here but not so
much remember this early decision h5 we
see how this plays a role later on in
the game
case in point rook takes h6 is available
and if King takes rook that's a pretty
cool mate you can't move the rook the
rook on e6 off of this rank and well
what else are you gonna do with this
rook black is without a move I guess the
only other move to maybe consider is
well can't I just maybe move the knight
no because there would be rook takes
rook and Queen to d3 if the Queen gets
into g6 you can kiss all these pawns
goodbye done so what is black do rook to
e7 this pawn is now going to drop after
rook takes b6 this game goes no further
black knows that he has dropped an all
too important pawn and with the b-pawn
around staying coordinated will become
all that more difficult impossible
really not only is the beep on now
passed but what about rook to b8 and
looking at these moves it's just too
much
Kasparov knows he's going down and
simply resigns if a couple more moves
were played out it may be something like
this you can't there's no stopping the
pawn black is not going to be in time to
coordinate against b7 it's just
impossible to do that so this is as far
as it went and this one rook takes b7
Kasparov throws in the towel an early
initiative out of this Sicilian Knight
orphe kicking off after that II five
move castles was much better
and yeah the kings of the initiative
Ivanchuk certainly took control at an
early moment anyhow as usual feel free
to leave any feedback to this video in
the comment section below I hope you
enjoyed it and maybe even took a thing
or two away that's all for now take care
bye
you